Billions of people died in Attack on
Titan. Hundreds have been killed in
Demon Slayer. But surprisingly only a
mere 80 people have died in One Piece.
So in this video, we will explain every single
character that has been killed in the story.
Starting with THE MOST GAME CHANGING DEATH
in the story, the execution of the former
pirate king, Gol D. Roger. He was killed
by these World Government executioners,
who can now actually claim the title of
killing the strongest pirate to ever live.
But this monumentous event occurred in the
very first page of the story after Roger had
already found the legendary island Laugh Tale.
But during his journey he became deathly ill,
so he decided to turned himself into the
marines. He did this so that he could
inspire the next generation of pirates to find
his legendary treasure and change the world.
However that is far the only death in chapter
1, and it’s kinda crazy that the very first
chapter of one piece is also one of the
bloodiest. Because we also have the death
of the captain of the mountain bandits. After
he kidnapped Luffy and clashed with Shanks,
he took Luffy out to sea where he was then eaten
by this giant sea monster. And interestingly,
this is actually the only time we have seen
a named character killed by a sea creature.
Kinda weird in a world filled with these
massive monsters. But even before this,
this random mountain bandit was shot in
the head by Shanks’ crewmate, Lucky Roux.
However, after three deaths in the very first
chapter, we have to wait almost two real years
until the next death in the story. In chapter
75, we meet the first of many random, unfortunate
characters to simply be in the wrong place at
the wrong time. This random marine commodore,
who actually has the hilarious name Pudding
Pudding, has come to save Nami’s hometown
from this ruthless group of fishmen. However,
Arlong’s henchmen sink the marine vessel before
even landing on the island. This sends sending
Pudding Pudding and his marines to a watery grave.
killer. And in fact Zoro is next on the list.
Jumping ahead a few more years, and in chapter
190 we learned that Zoro killed the former Mr. 7,
a special agent working for the warlod Crocodile,
sometime before the story began. Apparently
this Mr. 7 tried to forcefully recruit Zoro
to Crocodile, but clearly it didn’t end well.
But that’s not even the only one of Crocodile’s
subordinates to be killed, as Mr. 11 was shot dead
by a supposed ally, Mr. Mellow, in chapter 159.
Now staying in the sandy wastes of
Alabasta, these guys died by their own
hand while trying to take down the warlord
Crocodile. These are the Tsumegery Guards
and they willingly drank this deadly
Hero Water. Why you might ask? Well,
it gives you a ridiculous boost in strength, but
only lasts a few minutes before its effects turn
deadly for the user. And their sacrifice
just goes to show how truly desperate they
were to take down the warlord. And these
are the only official deaths in Alabasta,
except for any of the random characters who died
in the massive fighting during the civil war.
And this leads us to the absolute largest named
character to die in One Piece. This giant snake,
Kashigami, was worshiped by the
ancient people of Jaya. However,
that all changed when the snake god had
it’s head cut off by the explorer Nolan
in chapter 287. Nolan did this to save this
woman from being sacrificed. And while this
event initially caused much conflict, eventually
Nolan became greats friends with the tribe.
However, maybe the giant snake was actually
some kind of god, because karma came back to
bite Noland when he was executed by his own
kingdom. This was because he could not find
the famous city of gold a second time . But
this of course was not his fault, since the
golden city of Shandora was literally shot into
the sky. But don’t tell that to this greedy king.
And from one slimy killer to another, let’s
jump ahead six volumes to chapter 356. During
this chapter, the legendary shipwright Tom was
taken away and supposedly executed by Spandam,
one of the most hated characters in One Piece.
This was all a set up after Spandam had used
young Franky’s weapon to frame Tom. And
so even though it wasn’t Tom’s fault,
he accepted the punishment to save
his beloved apprentices. But yeah,
we really hate this guy. So please Robin, go
ahead, smack him around a bit more for us.
In fact, if we could wipe
out Spandam’s whole family,
the one piece world would be a lot better
off. Because Spandam’s father, Spandine,
was the main government agent who brought
mass destruction to the scholarly island,
it is nearly not as significant
as the next death on this list.
This man right here is Thatch, the second division
commander of the Whitebeard pirates. Or at least
he was, until he found the darkness logia devil
fruit, and was killed by Marshall D. Teach. And
at this point, Blackbeard, who was also a part
of Whitebeard’s crew, had been searching for
this fruit for twenty-six years. In fact, he
only joined Whitebeard because he thought it
was his best chance at finding this one super
special fruit. So Blackbeard literally stabbed
Thatch in the back and then left the Whitebeard
pirates for good. And while Thatch himself is
not super important, his death kicked off many of
the most important plot lines in the entire story.
Because after Blackbeard betrayed the crew,
Ace set out to hunt down the traitor for
revenge. And that all eventually led to Ace’s
capture and the whole war at Marineford. Plus,
this betrayal won Blackbeard his famous devil
fruit. Which is super game changing because
it is literally the most mysterious power and
helped him quickly become an Emperor of the Sea.
This takes us to Thriller Bark, where we
met this zombie pirate named Captain John.
And while he is already dead when we meet him
— wow that’s an odd statement, but whatever
moving on — we later learned in a question
corner that this former member of the
Rocks pirates was killed by his own crew
because he refused to share his treasure.
And if you think these betrayals are
downright disgusting, then make sure
to keep watching because it is NOTHING
COMPARED TO the next killers on this list.
In Sabaody, we meet these inhumanly cruel world
nobles. And in the space of just three chapters,
we see how truly awful these space-suit wearing
Celestial Dragons are. They needlessly kill not
one but two innocent people as if they were bugs.
And while we only see these two particular deaths,
we can assume that deaths like this are
common for anyone unfortunate enough to
encounter the Celestial Dragons. Seriously,
these dudes are twisted in all the worst ways.
Leaving behind Sabaody, our next death is a big
one, literally. This massive giant, Oars Jr,
was a longtime friend of Ace who was taken out
during the war at Marineford. And while it was
never confirmed that he was dead, he had his
whole leg sliced off by Doflamingo and he was
bombarded by attacks from countless marines. Plus
we’ve never seen him again in the story, so I am
assuming that he died, along with lots of other
random marines and pirates during this epic clash.
But of course Marineford also gave us THE SINGLE
MOST impactful death for Luffy in the entire
story. That’s because the whole point of the war
at Marineford was to save Luffy’s blood brother,
Ace, who was sentenced to execution by the World
Government after Blackbeard turned him in. And
while Luffy eventually freed him, the brothers
could not escape the wrath of the marine admiral
Akainu, who gave us one of the most soul-crushing
moments in the entire story. This moment broke
Luffy. Both physically and mentally. And I can
still remember the deep sadness that I felt seeing
this moment for the first time. And Luffy cannot
process his brother’s death either, and he goes
into this mindless coma which almost cost him his
life. But eventually this loss made him realize
that he was not strong enough to protect his
friends, so he decided to train for two years.
war showed us of the most insanely
overpowered fighters in the story,
none of them compare to the single most deadly
force in all of One Piece. That’s right,
I’m talking about: Stairs. Don’t believe me?
Well, just remember that these stairs easily
took out Zoro’s childhood friend, Kuina,
who literally defeated Zoro 2001 times. If
that’s not the definition of a monstrous
force of nature, I don’t know what is.
And if you want protection from this deadly stair
monster, make sure to subscribe to the channel.
But after Blackbeard’s complete betrayal
at marineford, we get another example of
crew on crew violence during the Ace, Sabo,
Luffy flashback. That’s because this guy,
Porchemy, was killed by his own captain,
Bluejam, for failing to beat up a young
Ace and Sabo. Speaking of Bluejam, I don’t
know about you, but I could really go for my
own jam sandwich right as we get to the
even deadlier second half of the story.
And after the two year timeskip,
and a month long break in real life,
we now move ahead to Fishman Island. In chapter
623 the chadliest of fishman, Fisher Tiger,
was killed by marines for simply returning
this lost child to her home. And this death
meant that fishmen continued to hate humans
for generations. But this hatred had serious
consequences later on because the human-hating
fishman Hoady Jones actually assassinated the
fishmen queen Otohime because of her ideals
about humans and fishmen getting along.
And soon after the fishman queen’s death, we
learned about the death of THE MOST MYSTERIOUS
CHARACTER in the entire story. When Robin
reads this poneglyph, she learns about Joy
Boy. The happily named figure was the leader
of the legendary ancient kingdom. While we
don’t know exactly what happened, we can assume
that he was killed during the battle with the
twenty kingdoms. These same twenty kingdoms would
eventually form the World Government. And while we
learned a bit more about Joy Boy during the Wano
arc, which I covered in depth in a previous video,
this is one death we absolutely have to
learn more about before the end of the story.
But one character we certainly won’t
be hearing from again is Vergo. This
man was posing as a marine while
actually working undercover for
Doflamingo. But after being stuck to the
railing of a laboratory by Trafalgar Law,
Vergo died in a massive explosion that
rocked the entire laboratory on Punk Hazard,
so congratulations you food loving man, you are
the first named character to die in the New World.
But Vergo was quickly joined by this Snow
Logia fruit user, Monet, who was seconds
away from blowing up the entire island with an
even bigger explosion. Unfortunately for her,
she was killed when Caesar Clown stabbed her
heart. But little did Caesar know that Law had
tricked him, and so he actually killed his own
subordinate instead of the marine admiral Smoker.
But as hard as it is to watch someone
accidentally kill their friend,
it is nothing compared to the tear-jerking,
sickening sadness of Law’s flashback. First,
we learned that basically Law’s entire
home island, including Law’s sister Lami,
were wiped out by neighboring countries because
of a misunderstanding about White Lead Disease.
Then during chapter 767, this evil young
Doflamingo became so disgusted by his own
father for taking away their status
as Celestial Dragons. So young Doffy
shoots Doflamingo Homing himself while his
brother cries in his father’s arms. Damn,
what a horrible little monster young Doffy was.
And in the very same chapter, we get the
heart-breaking conclusion to Law’s flashback.
And here we see Doflamingo’s brother Corazon steal
the Ope-Ope no mi to save Law’s from the deadly
White Lead Disease. He stole the fruit from Diez
Barrels, a pirate who wanted to sell the fruit
to the world government. And this turned out very
poorly for Barrels — I mean how couldn’t it with
a name like that. but Doflamingo later killed
Barrels because he wanted the fruit for himself.
But Doflamingo wasn’t done with his killing
spree yet, because in the same chapter,
Doflamingo executes his brother Corazon. And
this is honestly one of the saddest moments
in the story. Corazon fights to stay alive
to hide Law’s frantic cries from Doflamingo,
and he holds on just long enough
for Law to escape. However,
Law does eventually get his revenge
during the events of the Dressrosa arc.
But while Doflamingo is our current leading
killer with three, we jump ahead nearly two
years to Whole Cake Island, where Big Mom easily
takes the cake as the deadliest individual in
One Piece. We learn in a flashback from
chapter 850 that Big Mom killed Zepo,
the brother of everyone’s favorite
polar bear, Bepo. In that chapter,
we learned that she stole his entire lifespan as
punishment for trying to steal her Road Poneglyph.
And the deaths continued at the tea
party, when Katakuri killed this guy,
And then ten chapters after those horrifying
deaths, we get one of the most heroic sacrifices
in the story. As the straw hats attempt to escape
from Big Mom and her army, their ship is trapped
by Perospero’s sticky candy. So this leopard
mink, Pedro, sacrifices himself by blowing up
the candy trap with a ton of dynamite. And while
Pedro’s choice did allow the crew to escape,
it was devastating for their emotions. But it was
truly an inspiring scene, so please please Oda,
don’t ruin it by bringing him back to life.
And the next death is one that Sanji
would probably be happy to hear. And
that’s because this lion looking guy who ate the
invisibility devil fruit, Absolam, was killed by
someone from the Blackbeard Pirates. But it’s
not all good news for Sanji, who desperately
wanted the fruit. And that’s becasue Shiryu has
already eaten it and is using it to great effect.
And this takes us back into Wano, where
we have the most named character deaths
of any arc in the entire story. And it
starts with this smiling little man,
Yasuie. He was a former daimyo who became
the hero of the leftovers town until he
was caught stealing from the Flower Capital.
And this set up his execution in chapter 942,
when he reveals his true identity and
gives an inspiring speech to the crowd.
This sends the shogun Orochi and his men into
a frenzy and they kill Yasuie immediately.
But the porcupine haired man is not the
only Daimyo who meets their end during
the wano arc. In fact, these three former
Daimyos, Uzuki Tempura, Fugetsu Omusubi,
and Zoro’s great uncle, Shimotsuki Usihmaru,
were all killed by Kaido and his crew many
years before the start of the wano arc.
But it’s not just former samurai on Kaido’s hit
list, as the Emperor even killed one or possibly
two of his allies. This is Kurozumi Higurashi, the
previous user of the clone fruit. And her partner,
Kurozumi Semimaru, the previous user of the
barrier fruit. It was confirmed in chapter 972
that Kaido killed Higurashi for interfering with
his fight with Kozuki Oden. And while we don’t
know for sure, we can assume Semimaru also died
around this time since we never see him again.
And chapter 972 is also the spectacular climax
of Oden’s execution. He heroically survived in
a boiling pot of oil for an entire hour.
And because of his super impressive feat,
Oden’s retainers lived to carry
on his will. Unfortunately,
Oden himself was basically dead at this
point, and Kaido finished the job with a
bullet to the head. So in case you’re
keeping track, that’s six for Kaido.
Then just a single chapter later, Oden’s wife
Toki delivered a chilling prophecy that would
go on to haunt Orochi for twenty years. However,
the time fruit user was then shot and killed
by Kaido’s forces, just as she finished her
majestic speech. And I’m just now realizing
Oda really loves to kill characters right
after they says their truly epic lines.
And all this takes us to the epic conclusion of
the battle on Onigashima. But before we get there,
let’s go over some honorable mention killers who
we haven’t yet discussed in the story. First,
we have disease, which wiped out
Brook’s former captain, Yorki,
and his entire crew. It also claimed the live of
Señor Pink’s child and wife, Gimlet and Russian.
And it’s at this point, I’d also like to
mention Rocks D. Xebec. The former fleet
admiral Sengoku tells us that this legendary
former pirate was killed during the infamous
battle of God Valley. And while this may
be true and Rocks could actually be dead,
I find it entirely possible that he may still
be alive somewhere in the one piece world.
But the greatest honorable mention killer of
all is Oda-sensei himself, who loves to kill
a particular group of characters. And who
might this group of characters be, you ask?
Anyone in a flashback.
Well, yes, but no, not that
one. It’s actually: Mothers.
That’s right. There are almost no
significant mothers still alive in
the entire story. And that’s because Oda
thinks that if all the mothers were alive,
they would probably stop the kids from
becoming pirates. So Oda usually kills
them off in some tragic way that leaves
a lasting impression on the children.
For example, there was Usopp’s mom, Banchina,
who died from illness. Nami’s adoptive mother
Bellemere, who was killed by Arlong. Robin’s
mom, Nico Olvia, who died in the flames of
Ohara. Sanji’s Mom, Vinsmoke Sora, who also died
from illness. Portgas D. Rouge, who died from
childbirth while carrying Ace. Rebecca’s mom,
Scarlett, who was killed by Doflamingo’s right
hand man, Diamante. And that’s not even including
others we’ve already mentioned like Otohime,
who was the mother of the mermaid princess,
and Toki, who gave birth to Momo and Hiyori. Or
have the first of Oden’s Red Scabbards to meet
their end. This is Ashura Doji who was a mountain
gang boss until Oden came and tamed the wild lands
of Wano. And after the Scabbards failed to defeat
Kaido, they were confronted by a twisted version
of their former master. Ashura Doji realizes that
this is another clone created by their former
ally Kanjuro. And with his last act, Ashura Doji
tackles the false Oden and together they fall
into a fiery explosion. And while we’ve seen
characters survive damage like this before, it was
later confirmed that Ashura Doji did in fact die.
But speaking of Kanjuro, this traitor died in
a similar blaze of glory. After suffering many
fatal wounds when battling the Red Scabbard
Kin’emon, Kanjuro crawled back to Orochi’s
feet. Orochi then ordered him to create this
massive blob of hateful flames to consume
Kaido’s castle and everyone in it. And after
creating this beast, Kanjuro collapsed and die.
But his master would not survive much longer. Now,
Orochi seemed to die many times during the raid on
Onigashima, like when Kaido cut off his head, or
when the Scabbards took out many of Orochi’s snake
heads. However, he always reappeared because of
the special ability of Orochi’s Mythical Zoan:
Yamata no Orochi devil fruit. This fruit allows
him to have eight lives to go along with his
snake-like eight heads. But by the time we see him
in chapter 1048 he has already had seven of his
heads already taken out. Orochi is then confronted
by another of the Red Scabbards, Denjiro. And it
is fitting that Denjiro is the one to deal the
final blow, because he suffered for years secretly
plotting Orochi’s downfall for twenty years.
But with a last slash of his sword, Denjiro
finally slays the twisted shogun, brining Oden’s
revenge after twenty long years of suffering.
And good riddance to the most annoyingly
voiced character in the entire anime.
Unfortunately, there isn’t a completely happy
ending for the Scabbards. With Ashura Doji
already dead, the pistol-wielding Izou is battling
against agents of the world government’s CP0.
Already heavily damaged, Izou clashes with
this guy, Maha, one last time, and the pair
deal fatal blows to each other. Izou’s death was
later confirmed just like Ashura Doji’s, leaving
a bittersweet taste to the end of the war.
But since their famous battle cry Shunnachi
basically means that they will give THEIR ALL
to achieve victory, I think they will consider
it a sacrifice worth the freedom of their country
after over twenty years of oppression under Kaido.
But speaking of the big bad man himself,
this brings us to the end of the war on
Onigashima and the final two deaths
of the arc. Or, umm, possible deaths.
You see, in chapter 1040, the
tag-team duo of Law and Captain
Kid fully unleash their awakened devil
fruit powers to defeat Big Mom. First,
Law’s silencing bubble cancels out Big Mom’s
soul powers and then Kid’s super overpowered
railgun forces the helpless Big Mom out of the
castle and into a massive hole. And this pit
leads directly into a pool of volcanic
lava deep beneath the surface of Wano.
And if that molten lava is
not enough to kill Big Mom,
then I truly don’t know if she can
be killed in the story. But for now,
we are led to believe that she is dead, since much
time has passed and she still hasn’t reappeared.
And the same could be said for the
strongest creature in the world,
Kaido. As the truly epic clash atop the skull dome
came to its end, Kaido used this insanely massive
fire dragon form that towered over the island
itself. As Kaido flew up up into the clouds,
he was met by an even bigger Gear 5 Luffy.
And with this mind-blowingly massive punch,
he crushed Kaido all the way down into
the same underground lava pool as Big Mom,
which led to a giant volcanic eruption as
Luffy was declared the victor of the battle.
And while this was truly an epic moment in the
story, we have to give the same disclaimers for
Kaido’s death as we did with Big Mom. Kaido might
have somehow survived this titanic explosion,
but for now we are meant to believe that the two
Emperor’s of the Sea are well and truly dead.
And so after four years in the most
deadly arc to date, the story moved on
to an even more shocking death, or should
I say, deaths, than anyone could imagine.
First, in chapter 1054, Nefertari Cobra, who
is the father of Vivi and the king of Alabasta,
was killed during the meeting of the World
Government’s rulers. And this is a truly
game changing death, since it was blamed on
Luffy’s blood brother Sabo. And while no one
really believes that it was Sabo, this is hugely
important because not only was Cobra secretly one
of Luffy’s allies, but he was also one of the few
actual “good” kings in the story. If anyone was
going to try to change the government for good, it
was going to be him. So with him dead, this means
that we may be getting an even more sinister world
government that we have had thus far in the story.
And this leads directly to the destruction of an
ENTIRE ISLAND. In an unthinkable display of power
either the Five Elders, or Imu, the secret ruler
of the World Government, unleashed this massive
blast of laser beams that took out the entire
kingdom of Lulusia. This includes King Seki and
princess Komane. And this event in chapter 1060
brings to light the truly terrifying powers of
the world government. They simply decided
that this kingdom was going to be erased,
and this mysterious weapon of destruction was
able to make it a reality. Now we don’t know
if this is a devil fruit power or possibly
the ancient weapon Uranus, but either way,
this is destruction on a scale WAY BIGGER than
anything we have ever seen in the story. Which
makes me wonder if this was how God
Valley was also erased from the map.
And this takes us to the current story arc,
Egghead Island. On this island we are actually
given a genuine murder mystery for the first
time in the story. This mystery came to an
epic conclusion in chapter 1077 when Shaka,
the Vegapunk satellite who represents Logic,
was shot in the head by the traitor of Egghead
Island. And while we don’t truly know
if Shaka is dead, the traitor York,
who is the Vegapunk satellite representing Greed,
certainly acted like he was out of the picture.
And just two chapters later, we get
the most undeniably badass one-shot
K.O. in the entire story, courtesy of
the Yonko Red Haired Shanks. You see,
with Captain Kid pulled up on Elbaf and was about
to take out Shanks’ entire fleet. However, Shanks
delivers a single godly conqueror’s haki
infused slash that takes out Kid and almost
all of his crew. And then this assault was
followed up by a simply massive dual sword
blast from the giants Dorry and Broggy which
sent Kid and his crew sinking to the bottom
of the sea. And while we don’t yet know if Kid
will survive this ordeal, the incredible hype
surrounding this feat leads me to believe
that he might actually be dead for good.
And as devastating a blow that will be to Kid fans
everywhere, it is not the first time Kid has been
beaten down. In fact, did you know that he was
actually beaten up by his very first lover? Or did
you know that Shanks might have been born on God
Valley? Well, if you want to know more about every
single tragic, epic, and heartwarming backstory
in One Piece, you can watch this video right here.
Shanks for watching.